Hey guys, you guys have heard of ASMR, right? So Ed, do we know what ASMR stands for? What's the deal with it? What's the deal with what you guys are talking about? ASMR is when you talk really slow. Does it feel like I'm everywhere in your head? Can we guess what the acronym is for something? Yeah, sure, go ahead.
Acute sound. I need to ask you again, does it feel like I'm just everywhere? Because I am, I'm in your head. I am you. Yeah. I am all of you. Acute sound. Jason, close your eyes.
Close your eyes. Look, it's me. In here. I'm in here with you. I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go upstairs. I'm gonna turn on the camera. Oh my God. How did you get in here?
Okay. I think we got it. We got it. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help.
Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. So guys, I'm sorry I'm late. I start with a reason why you're not wearing a hat. Why we got to look at what we're... Is skevo on holiday?
What's going on with skevo? No, on skevo. Did we talk last time about that I met skevo? No. No, but I know that you did. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I was in there getting this done to my head. Oh, it looks good, by the way, Jay.
I paid for it, believe it. It looks really good. Stop it. It does the lightness better. And then there was skevo. And skevo, like, is not nearly as... God, I gotta say this kindly. The name will point you in a certain direction of anticipation.
And here's this, like, Greek god. And he's beautifully short of that. Yeah. Yeah, he's a pretty cool dude. Yeah. Okay, so Sean, so you're sorry you're late today because... I was one minute late. I'm not making this up.
I literally just went to the mail and something was dropped over the fence and it's for Scotty and it's from this company. Bear bottom. B-E-A-R-B-O double... It literally describes him in two words. A bear bottom... He's a bear and he's a bottom. Listen, this is great to know.
I swear to God, I just picked it up in the mail. Does it say noisy on the other side? Does it say power? It's sloppy. So what does bear bottom make for clothing? I don't know. Should I open it? Oh, they're nice.
Oh, they're like shorts. Oh, they're just shorts. They're shorts. I would like to say the one thing I did think about to... I mean, we rarely do think of anything to say on this show, non-shocker. It's important. It's just how much this is not working for me, Will. You spending your summer out of town.
I don't know. I don't get it. I mean, I get you've got a lot of money and people with a lot of money need to figure out ways to spend it and you found one there. But this isn't working for us. Well, like Jay and I are going to the Dodgers game tonight. Yeah, and like you should be there. I was invited to go with you guys.
Obviously, you know that and I would love to go with you and... But who is this good for? I bet you it weirds the kids out. The dogs probably all freaked out. What's this house? Well, the kids were missing you. The kids love it. The kids love being out here and, you know, obviously I used to live in New York.
And so I sold my apartment and I bought a house out at the beach, which is why I'm here and I like it out here. I think I do not sing Long Island anymore. I mean, let's stop hiding. You live in the Hamptons, you know? How many very Range Rovers are in the driveway? Zero. You got those in LA?
All GMCs. They're all GMCs. Why? Because they're professional. Well, we are professional grades. Sure. I got a new AT4X on its way. It's a beautiful pickup truck from GMC. I saw pictures of that. It's good looking.
It's real handsome. I'm coming out there in two weeks. It's got a multi-pro tailgate. No, you're coming out in two weeks, Sean. What are you guys coming for? One night. What night is it? I don't remember.
Just one night. I don't understand. Because then you're flying to come see me. Where are you going to spend seven nights with me? Well, maybe like four. Really? We're going to get a tour of NASA in Florida first. Before I see you.
And then you're going to go to the Bahamas and do a tour of NASA. Wonderful, Will. Are we rolling, guys? Did you get any of that? I love getting instant feedback. Anyway, let's get to it. Let's get to it. Because I think you're going to be happy.
Okay. Today, we have a man who is half of a famous comedy duo. He's been educated by the smart folks at Sarah Lawrence. He's performed at Second City in Chicago, Sean. He's starred in two big TV shows,
probably more, just not good at research. Produced a few of them, probably more, not good at research. He's voiced characters in multiple animated hit films. But you know him and love him for his recent work behind the camera as a writer, producer, and bad-ass director of three incredible films,
two of which we've seen. These have yielded four Academy Award nominations and one win. His new film will undoubtedly add to all of that because it looks triple good. Or as the kids like to say dope, which rhymes with nope, which is the name of the film.
Here's Jordan Peele! No way! Look at that. No one's ever taken a bow, you guys. Wow. You took a bow like the opposite way. Your head went way up. I took a bow on an audio podcast.
Jordan, I was just talking about you today. Don't choke the puppy. Just ease off. I was just talking about him today. I had to just say that. Here I am in the flesh. I'm very excited that you're here. This is so exciting.
It's so exciting to meet you. We're going to get to it, but it's like the number one movie I'm most excited to see. I watched the trailer a half a dozen times. I've seen the trailer a million times. That's fantastic. I've seen the clicks that you've put on the YouTube trailer.
He's got a lock on our IP address. Thank you. While we're talking about the trailer here, do you cut your own trailers? Or do you have meaningful consultation? I love that phrase. Or do you let the fine folks at Universal get it all done and vendor that stuff out?
Because the trailers for your films are equally incredible. You can't use vendor as a verb. Don't say vendor that stuff out. That's one of the grossest things. But you just tried to slide in there, and it's one of the most disgusting things. And a fucking long list of just...
Can I talk to you for a second? Yes. I'm really nervous. Guys, whenever you're ready, I can. Hey, man, we're back. So we're talking trailers? Did you get your hands on that at all? Well, yeah, man.
I think a lot of directors are envious of the trailers that I get to put out. And I have to give Universal marketing just a lot of credit. They bring just great work and they're collaborative. We've had success from Get Out.
Right. So they'll let you poke around. Oh, yeah, they'll let me poke around. They'll let me poke around. In the very beginning, we had to make some strong decisions. In Get Out, the whole question of do you let out that rose
that the evil white girl, that the white girl is evil, do you let that out? Is that the thing that's going to bring the evil white girl movie? Okay, well, now I have to see the evil white girl movie. And so we together chose not to do that and we made the right choice, I think.
But it meant that you couldn't really put a certain section of the film in the materials, right? Yeah, that's right. But it was worth it. It was the right move. Get Out is also one of my favorite movies of all time. Well, thank you.
And I love it, so I've seen it a million times. No, it's fine. But if that number just pops up. Yeah, that number is just fucking, that's it. Yeah, no, we have it on record. That was your first movie you ever directed? First movie ever? First movie ever.
And how did that happen? Because it's flawless. Oh, stop. And it wins an Academy Award for writing it. I know. You guys, you got too much. Did you have a sit down with yourself or with someone else you probably would say,
now, baby, you're probably going to witness for the next 20, 30 years is just a rapid descent from the peak of the, like, how could it ever get better? Were you prepared for just like, it's too much too soon? And then you went ahead and doubled it
with us, probably tripled it with, I mean, just look at it though. Probably. Well, thank you. No, I mean, yeah, dude, it was so much pressure yet at the same time, you know, so many opportunities opened up because of that thing and literally the opportunity
to say, okay, what story, you know, to be able to write something knowing it's going to get made is a whole different thing. Right, yeah. And that it's got to be at least as good because they're going to be waiting for you to be a one hit wonder. Right.
And then like all of that pressure to still let your creativity come through without having it be muted and angled by that pressure. How did you push through that? You know, you embrace the risk that only you can take, because that's really the position you're at.
You have more leeway, so you have to take a big gobble of risk and do something you're kind of not supposed to do each time. And that was us. And that was us to me at the time. You swung and you nailed it. Thank you, man. Thank you.
I'm so proud of these movies. I'm so proud of this movie. I'm about to unleash on the world. When does it come out? When does it come out? It comes out the 22nd. 22nd of July. So this might be right around that time.
Jordan, I want to say, let me ask you this question. You know, obviously, I think one of the most trailblazing TV shows of the last 25 years, you guys wrote some unbelievable sketches on that show that are still memorable
that I still go and look at today. And I'm not one of those people who constantly goes like, hey, you know, brings up bits that other people do for whatever reason, but your sketches from that show for me have been a touchstone of really funny,
really original. I love, I mean, I'm not unique in that way, but I love really original comedy and you guys did incredible original comedy. And how much writing of that do you think prepared you for this next chapter that you're in now?
Writing sketch because it's such a discipline, right? Because I think all of us are like, we love you from, just to piggyback on what Will says, we all obviously love you from key and peel and everything you've done before Get Out. So when Get Out came out, we're like, wait, what? But it's not surprising because you wrote some great sketches. No, not the talent.
Was that like a training ground, do you think? Did that sort of give you a kind of discipline? To be good, fast? Yeah, I mean, fuck, yeah. You know, the sketch to me is about a couple of things that I think the movies are also about. And with sketch
you get this, one of the things you get is a great training ground for just that, getting to sort of push the boundaries and understand audience. And you get to commit to something just for three minutes at a time and sometimes you take too big a swing,
sometimes you don't take big enough a swing, but you get calibrated in that whole, in what to swing for, right? And so I think a lot of what I think makes one of my movies, one of my movies is that you know, from the early stages
and every stage through I am trying to think of how can that how can I take a risk? What is the right risk to take here? Because that's what people need. That's what people really deserve is something that's fucking sketchy to do and to pull off
and to convince the studio to let you do has to be that. Well, like a lot of your sketches you guys would take a kernel of an idea and you would keep doubling down on it and keep heightening it in a way that was like, and you were like, oh fuck these guys now they're heightening it again
which is just the nature of really good comedy, right? Well this is you guys, you know this is these are the rules that all you guys fucking do every day, you know these things and yeah, it felt a bit, there was a vacuum there for a minute where it felt like
you know, we've had these great sketch shows that come along and just and live in color and Mr. Show, Chapelle, you know you have these moments where these things happen that's different and it hadn't happened for a while. So then you get into writing Get Out
which is just comes you know, just absolute like a freight train just man just hits everybody and it just part really becomes just part of the for a while there just it was the it thing culturally in that movie
really, really grab people and again though I was going to say like you kind of use the same principles, right? Like you just kept doubling down on the idea and you kept pushing it out further you talked about that before like how far can I push this idea
what more can I do and surprise people I think that's it it's the element of surprise. Yeah, how did you think what I mean you've been asked this a million times and forgive me I don't know the answer but every time I watch Get Out and like I said one million times how did you think how
I mean it's such a bizarre brilliant concept. Wow, where did you get the idea? The idea you know honestly it's just it's life right I mean there's this that there's this group of wealthy people that buy body parts I mean it's so not yeah well
the whole thing started with just that feeling okay if I can if I can capture a feeling, a horror a fear that I haven't seen bottled in a film before if I can identify that fear I can make
a horror movie out of it because it's there right just the way in sketch comedy if you get it if one thing you say can get a laugh I know all you guys if you get a laugh once you can get it a million times and you can keep getting it you know how to do that. Just say sashimi
yeah yeah a million times yeah and then same kind of thing I was like I know this nugget of I am this fear of being in the most the black guy in a white space
where you're feeling feeling the attention and it's not good even if it feels even if it's supposed to be a nugget and it's this thing that I know that everyone recognizes in their own way but so anyway so it started with like that
party sequence in a way was like okay that's the movie yeah but there's a there's an element to what you do that you would assume could only really happen after a lot
of practice and a lot of exposure to the filmmaking process and that is this ability to create an unsettling environment and there's there's a camera component to that there's a sonic component to that an editorial pace to that
there's a lighting component to that where did you find all of that and learn all of that I mean right out of the gate and get out the scene on the street at night there was so much patience that you it was like I'm already
nervous out of my mind because things aren't I think was it a runner I think that yeah I mean like where do you where do you get off doing that right if you're paying attention it's one right out of the gate were you encouraged
by a DP that you hired were you or is it just you're just a baller are you there are you still with us Tracy sorry is that what you talk about Tracy when some kind of business jargon there's that but then there's also
he's apologizing for my long-winded questions which I am Sean's sister lives in Wisconsin and her name is Tracy and so we always explain to Tracy DP means cinematographer and oneer is DP can mean cinematographer yeah Tracy look up that shit yourself Tracy look it up
so where do you get all of this filmmaking talent is probably the better economical way to ask it thank you what a lovely question it's watching movies it's watching movies and by the way like I started as a puppeteer as what I went to college thinking
I was gonna do something like that that's crazy come on yeah this totally on this sort of vanquish art form that I thought was kind of beautiful and special can't really fail at it but the whole notion is
this illusion right and then since then I've just I've acted I've written I've done a lot I just had a great experience in the other pieces where did you start puppeteering seems so hard because you have to keep your arms up
or down it doesn't matter just elevate yourself and you can hang them down a little bit Sean god where did you start where was that going on Jordan I don't even know where you go when I went to Sarah Lawrence kind of like my cheeky in like a liberal arts college
answer to what my major was was I'm a puppeteer that's so cool sculpture, theater classes you know I was like real real bohemian puppeteer at Sarah Lawrence
that's all the girls needed to hear right yeah he's a fucking what he's a what he does what with his hands but where does the confidence come to trust that you're going to be able to transition an audience from something that seems fairly normal
into something that is abnormal you obviously know how to do that in comedy right because you got to sort of present as just well we're just you and then we do something that's a little bit on that's surprising and then there's the surprise that comes with the laugh
is it the same kind of thing with doing horror is it the same kind of calculation what a horror yes yes yeah yeah with horror it is connected and you know I know you I know you play around with this
in your own work there's a rhythm I always find that horror and comedy are sort of baked into one another because it's about grounding and absurdity as best as possible both both is taking a swing to something that is either going to make you
fucking you know terrified or make you absurd in some way and making it real and the difference can be the difference between two pieces of music I was just going to let you know I don't know if you know this I don't know if you know that I'm Canadian
and they changed your movie the title get out in Canada they called it get out okay that's great guys you again Rob Bennett are you guys are rolling on all this stuff they're not going to cut that out you dick no no I just want to make sure we got that I want to make sure we got that
do they spell it two O's and a T Will just to finish the joke oh sorry Jason what are you asking Jordan about the lighting packages you fucking dick here we go I don't know what I was saying I don't know what it was we don't either
and we will be right back and now back to the show now when you come up with these original ideas because none of them are like it's incredible premises and concepts is it because Donna Langley and Peter Kramer
are so darn smart and courageous at Universal that they're saying yeah great go or are you having to do a bunch of tricks to talk them into don't worry this is going to be commercial like the real questions yeah I mean how do you they're original ideas and you're getting
this major studio to fund you know something that's not kind of boilerplate concept I had the same question you know we've had a couple of situations where they've taken on the risk
and it's paid off you know for this one I felt very very trusted and you know the way I talk to those guys is I sound I hear this you sound great you sound fucking cool
you're not going to sell pickup trucks like Will Arnett you sound raspy I sound like Weezy Weezy but I mean they gave me a lot of leeway to do some crazy shit in the movie
but there's these highbrow themes underneath all of this sticky you know fun popcorn stuff too I mean you're doing it all good how does it happen Jason real quick
is there too much drool your jealousy is showing no it's aberration I was going to ask you about Chelsea so I know Chelsea as well and how did you guys how did you and Chelsea meet? we met on the internet
I DMed her after I heard her on a podcast I saw her and do some stand up and I was basically DMed her and it was that's cool sometimes it works
load up Paredi on the straight DMs can you tell you how old you have a young boy or girl I got a boy named Bo can we tell yet whether he's a smart one or a dumb one
he's a very smart he's a reader he's a brilliant wow he's smarter than Jason already I'm sure we share some faults let's put it that way his faults I realized tell me what you're bad at
what am I shit at I'm really bad at keeping things clean I just see somebody and just being and spacing out being on my wife's existence you'll just check out yeah and I'll try and
it's one of these things you're talking to your son just Bo Bo and just nothing and I realize I'll do the same thing I realize he'll be saying dad 10 times and I'm like maybe that's just concentration and that's focus and that's discipline
that's what I think is happening I had Alessandro just told me very recently that I was getting to remember again what it was but I asked her something and she goes I've told you the answer to this like four times in the last 24 hours was it her last name? I'm the same way
why are we all that way this is actors motherfucker we're all dumb asses we're all inside our head my memory works just for learning lines that's it okay wait hold on a second I don't know how much time we have
I just want to respond to Jason yes sir you're very nice things but I want to say I don't know how much it's stressed but you are the first guys let him finish this sounds like it might be a compliment
you are the first fucking dry delivery comedy guy I've ever seen in my life I've ever seen in my life first dry I've never seen it before I'm talking about fucking Hogan wow Hogan family
let's go back a bit talking about seeing bro we're talking about Hogan okay this is coming out of like right this is coming out of an Alice P. Keaton sort of universe where you got this you know Michael Jag jump around but you came in
with this cadence that I swear it's the best has it ever happened before Jordan it's so fucking good JB's let's go on JB little compliment motherfuckers copied and motherfuckers came and copied
they all copied I was stealing too many Jason invented really when that became a big thing I'm telling you and remember how mad I got about that because I was like that's fucking Bateman's and I'd see these motherfuckers doing it on other shows and doing it as punchlines in commercials
and they're like really and I'm like that's Batman fucking invented and we did it on a recipe I was copying him I was copying him meanwhile here's the other thing when I first met Jason we were throwing the pilot for rest development this is one of my favorite
it's such a dumb joke we're in this rehearsal hall and this guy comes in he's a crew guy and he's covered in tats the neck, hands, everybody just covered and he walked in like right in front of us and kind of like started talking to somebody and Jason full volume because he wasn't
knew that the guy wouldn't know who's your top dog who's your tippy and I fucking I fell to the ground I was crying yeah I've just been trying to do Bill Murray my whole life right or John Cleese
or Ben Stiller it didn't hit like that it didn't hit like that I never thought it was quite enough so I took it and just really notched it up you did you put tap shoes on it
yeah I put tap shoes on and I didn't think nobody it's not going to read so I just really hit the back of the room with that but it is it's worth it's worthy of nothing you're very nice thank you you had mentioned that a lot of the inspiration for not only Get Out but Nope and all of your stuff is from movies you've seen
what are your inspirations what movies do you draw upon and do you are stuck in your head as inspirations yeah who's done it really really well that you're dying to do it as good as I would say you have no equal but like who's been pulling you and hopefully there's a compliment but just from the trailer
of Nope I'm like oh it's very M Night but now I go oh it's very Jordan Peele oh thank you I'm a big M Night fan I think he's one of the greats I love I'm kind of a it's kind of a boring answer because I
like Kubrick and Spielberg and Hitchcock that's the one and Tito I'm joking I'm being glib but I like what people go I don't know I mean for me I like the Beatles oh do you
oh you like the Beatles yeah yeah yeah well that's me while we're here my favorite Sean Hayes story did not know Beatles was spelt B-E-A-T no by the way just my favorite by the way penis lots of people no comments also agreed with me
I didn't know we were calling Bateman penis I didn't even know that that was a thing they're pity tweets wait wait so sorry Jordan you like Spielberg and you like Kubrick stuff that's cinematic stuff now that you put it like that fucking well I like fucking John
I don't know I'm with you by the way I'm fucking with you so I'm just while we're there that cinematic tightens like those guys can you just indulge me for one second before we lose the audience about your pursuit and landing of Hoyta where that came from
this is a cinematographer like this guy's just nails how do you get well I tell you how you get him you make two great movies but like was it was it as incredible as you thought it would might be like I would imagine it would be
different level right so I mean I've had I've worked with great cinematographers I've got I've gotten very lucky in all my films I mean with Hoyt I really got a guy who's done it all is that how you say it Hoyt it's he said Hoyt
Hoyt Hoyt Hoyt Hoyt you can say it either way I say it either way I just never known he's a he's an absolute beast I mean he's just and what what we were able to do with this movie is push ground in ways that
I don't even really want to talk about because I don't want to take some of the experience from the audience but you know we push technology with infrared cameras and he's just he yeah so we got on this it was just
like it's just exactly what you want as a director like this adventure where you're in over your head but you've got this salt of the earth fucking DP who knows it all who's like this guy's just Dutch guy this jolly
Dutch guy with his beard and he's like he's gonna be alright we're gonna figure this out by the way that's a good Dutch accent that's fucking great yeah I just like I don't know how do you gather when you have such a specific and unique flavor to your films how are you able to crew that and cast that appropriately
to where everybody is as crafty and clever as you are because they all just vendor it or do you just vendor it you vendor it because I have Apple pay but I'll take Venmo it's I mean you know the thing it's like the team building is the
thing if you get that part right it it really flows but um yeah you you just talk to people who for me I'm talking to people who are inspired by the idea and in a way that it's not you know in every
department it's not gonna be me telling saying this is what goes it's gonna be me about the collaboration between me and this person so if I'm excited about what they're excited about and maybe they're excited about something that I didn't even know to be excited about letting them do their thing we're going in that direction
together yeah did you did you so you touch on something really briefly in there when you were talking you said that you don't want to take away from people's experience and I don't know if I've had this experience myself I remember doing answering something questions
about when we were doing Bojack Horseman a few years ago and I kind of and I kind of didn't want to be too much of a dick about it and I said you know I feel like sometimes there's too much emphasis on you know how the sausage is made and not enough enjoying of the sausage
and and I kind of got that feeling when you said that that it's like look I could talk ad nauseam about how I made this film and what kind of cameras and what kind of shots we did but you didn't do make the film so that you could explain that to the audience you did
all that shit and hopefully it's seamless and they don't know what that is and they just they experience it is that right that's right and you know the only the only reason I bring it up is to give white no you didn't bring it up yeah I'm dorking out yeah fair enough but but the but
the yeah I mean the the only reason I even tell you that there was some really interesting ground pushed at all so it is just so you know like yeah that hope to answer that question he's he's a real master yeah and
you again you didn't bring it up and obviously this is what we do and so we're asking the questions because we are and Jason's interested in our audiences too and I and Sean and I are really interested but I just mean more generally do you feel sometimes like you wish that you didn't have to answer
questions about it and just let it the work speak for itself does that ever is that ever something that kind of annoys you or gets in the way you know I think it can get in the way and it was an interesting experience because I think with get out
you know it you know get out you know it had a lot of success but it was also there was a lot I was talking about it a lot yeah and and sort of trying to help that audience put together the dots on it and I don't know
if it needed that maybe not you know in the long run but to get people to see it and you know my entry point into film was sort of telling people what I did you know when it got to us you know all of a sudden we have something that is a bit of a vaguer notion of how to
discuss and so I felt like the responsibility to that film was to not sort of take the audience through it but to let them experience it more you know I think with this film I'm gonna approach it letting the
film lead a bit but you know I do want the audience to know it was about spectacle and that it was about the theatrical experience in its core in this idea of I felt like
alright I've got this position I've got this responsibility to try and do that thing where I make some original shit that's just a fucking spectacle. The title cannot be beaten No better title for any film Can you tell us
a little bit like just from a fan's point of view like I am like can you tell us a little bit about nope like can you tell us what the word nope means in the movie or what we're looking at in that trailer that they're looking at any kind of exciting anything Yeah I mean look
it's I'll say this it's a word that's said a lot in the movie and it generally is something that you know part of the notion of this movie is like we got a big budget flying saucer movie
with black people in the lead that to me in itself you know there's no there's no need to really dig further in terms of how to push the conversation then there's a fucking do it right that should be
that should just be on the one sheet by the way that's it right and well and then I mean it kind of is it's like the no part of it is I think an acknowledgement that you know it is a different movie you can't just make the same movie
you know and there is an experience that people want to see deal with this shit as well and you know I and I would also say it's a film that that feels like it's a concept
in a way but you know there is also an acronym to it that I think a lot of people online have sort of piece together well I think I know what it is you want to guess you go for it and you don't have to say yes or no not of planet earth
well yeah did you just know that Will you're not that smart I thought you were going to say something funny and wrong not of planet earth it's pretty good but that was not funny and right wait how in the world did you I would have never
that's gotta be it well that's the end of the interview thanks so much I'm good at wordling that's pretty wild you sure are boy this guy alright now because of getting back to sort of your taste
your radar for uniqueness and originality what are you watching what are you reading that keeps that sharp that keeps you kind of not postmodern but knowing where the next idea is going to come from
that's going to make the last idea seem not so original it's a great question there's so much immersion into my own of my own ass that it's hard to you say you smoke a lot of weed
it's as simple as just getting the right strain of indica well I see what you're saying even when I'm fucking yes first of all yes when I'm coming up with shit that is kind of an important piece of the puzzle you know I like anime
because anime is just high concept world building that is pulled off so well it's these big swings and there's it's a great way
to free yourself look you can tell a fucking crazy story and people do pull that shit off there are storytellers in the world that are pulling off really crazy things that are super popular that's one place
gotcha are you watching any comedy I find it hard to watch comedy I know it's broken I think it's probably broken for us where is it on television or is it on film right now
or is it on stage, stand up where is funny shit happening some funny shit you know what's funny pen 15 is funny I just worked with Gabe Liedman who created that show I don't know
I haven't seen shit but it is I do feel like we've been in this weird comedy drought where people want to laugh but somehow it's hard isn't it a lot like it's just become
fragmented with tiktok and instagram where you can get your comedy filled through 5 second 10 second things so people are maybe not so inclined to go tune into an entire series I don't know just throwing that out there I have an idea
that from my own experience in dealing with streamers they tell us that they have a hard time getting people to stay through and watch multiple episodes in comedy it's really really really really difficult
we'll be right back and now back to the show now is Chelsea a good sounding board for you reading pages or drafts or watching cuts of things and giving you good feedback
I know it's always tricky with a partner that little balance there I'm sure she's incredibly helpful but that's a dance right she is one of the reasons I love her she's always going to be honest
and tell me the truth it's like there's a certain point in the industry where I'm sure you guys know there's nothing more attractive than that we're all lucky on this call here
now what about it looked like you shot this thing in town here in Los Angeles in Santa Clarita perhaps as the website says by the way guys correct me if I'm wrong here Jordan
this is the first time that a film has an amusement park there at Universal Studios tour being released germane to the movie on the same day the movie is being released
usually a movie has to earn that by becoming super successful and then 4, 5, 6 years later they have like a ride he's got a you explain it Jordan but it's incredible what he's done here it's a big deal for me
I'm in Universal Studios I remember going when I was 12 you see like fake it's like the experience like the fake version of what it means to make a movie it's like this is where Jaws was shot
it's like no it's not but it's like psycho house the whole like artifice that was Jason's backyard he played there when he was a kid no joke just do it
silver spoons and it's your move Ricky would fart around back there on our bikes anyway so you know how when I went for the first time I was just blown away and so now we're on the lot now
and just feel that magic again and yeah we've got Stephen Yin's character who is an amusement park called Jupiter's Claim and it's one of the centerpieces of the film and so that's going to be on the studio tour like fucking in between
the psycho house and Jaws and is it sort of without giving away anything with the movie is the ride of this place is it kind of like a haunted house or a fun house like the website is
that you can kind of click around on like all of the things on that tour there is going to be a certain amount of interactivity got it but the thing that real movie nerds are going to geek about
upon the the hopeful embrace of this film is that it's there that's so cool they did that that is really really awesome now do you have to fly around and do a bunch of promotion for this or are you able to do it all with zoom
nowadays with the COVID or they got you on a world tour or something I'm going to do a tour they're going to cart me away to some places I'm just going to shut my eyes and open them and try to figure out where I am
and then do you like to take some down time before you start writing the next thing or are you already underway with that you know writing is kind of I mean it is the down time there's nothing more fun than being in those early stages of
what is really the next one I mean it's a very relaxing if I'm doing it right it's a very freeing month you know do you want to like stay in the horror genre for a while or is there some kind of dream of like wanting to do something completely
you know left turn a musical one of the things that has been is fun for my journey in these first three films has been a little bit of the deconstruction of what I feel like
genre is and what the role of genre is in storytelling I love that I like this yeah you like this one so in that first one in that first one I was really using a very specific type of suspense thriller
genre trope and you know get out it fits in that world and so that helps the pieces of it I think that are outside of the box sing because there is a
checkpoint there's a genre checkpoint that's genre I think you use very well at least for you know it worked so then you know us I really kind of focused on the horror idea you know and the specificness of no something a little bit more
threatening to the core of existence and scary in that way and in a lot of ways worked within that genre as well you know with this one I feel like this idea that's been bubbling in these other two films
with no I think has come into fruition where I can't really pin it down to a genre anymore it kind of it is all things and I think I probably could do that
you've kind of delved into a lot of bigger issues and I would suggest I didn't even think of get out as a horror movie at all and I'm saying horror I didn't think of it as a horror movie at all I thought of I mean it is I guess that's like a thriller yeah it's a thriller
but you I mean you're dealing with a lot of like big issues you're asking a lot of questions and you're making some you're bringing up a lot of things that I think make some people uncomfortable and I think you're doing it in a way you're serving it in a way that is like maybe seems familiar
to them but then you're like but guess what motherfucker you better think about this and think about what the experience is other people who aren't you maybe having and you kind of do it and maybe us is about like our own you sort of mentioned it like it's very sort of
an existential question about you know as human beings and blah blah blah I like the idea that you're you're kind of like I guess they're in horror but you're dealing with a lot of pretty fucking big universal issues it doesn't seem like you're you set out
to make a horror movie or a genre movie you're making seems like you're leading with theme and then kind of backing into well maybe this medicine will go down well if we wrap it up with something that's a little bit kind of scary here or sci-fi here
I withdraw my question no but I mean in the same way that you lampooned it when you when you did key and peel man you did a lot of you took on so many sketches that you did where you took on the idea of race and challenged it and did it from a different perspective in ways
that were really funny but also like really fucking right on the fucking money man and you've kind of you're kind of doing that same thing but now in it and you're doing it in film and you're using I mean I sound like now I sound like Babin but you're using light and you're using no when you're
you're doing it in a cinematic way like you're I like I think that you defy genre so anybody who says that Jordan Peele is this I say fuck that he's everything oh well yeah well thank you and at the same time you know just to stress you know I think a lot of people
you know if I make any sort of distinctions from like the horror genre at all I I want you know a lot of people think a horror is a bad word sure I think it's actually the greatest genre and and I think it is
one that I'm honored to to take part in the true I have to say the true spirit of great horror is really to fuck somebody up on some on some terror level that I still have not
sort of approached the darkness that is needed so I just have so much respect for horror and I'm so I'm honored to be a part of it yeah and and I didn't mean to suggest that it wasn't that it wasn't worthy but at all as genres
go it's fucking great I agree with you I'm just saying that yeah I think that what you do kind of transcends transcends the idea of genre yeah and it seems like you're using it or attracted to it because of it it's it's power and it's accelerant for whatever sort of human condition
story you're talking about like you know when you mention Kubrick like you think about you know the only thing that he ever did that was close to horror was the shining and there wasn't a lot of that wasn't you know there wasn't some slasher film you know that you know a bunch of jump scares it was just
deeply unsettling but it was earned through its filmmaking through its acting through its writing through its cinematic elements I mean like that's what you do you're not like anybody can like make a big sound and do a big you know fucking snap zoom or
whip pan and like scare somebody you know like you're not doing that you're creating these environments that are unsettling and that's not easy to do and I just I think you're just like like the most exciting filmmaker we've got right now thank you man look
I you guys are fucking awesome I mean I think you know just the last shit stories as in as in what you've been in a set in the middle of nowhere and you really got it out of the bathroom but there's nothing around there we go Sean's going to watch it on a set
no no no I'm kidding you're just kidding but but no I mean let's just talk about the set portos for a second sure yeah yeah yeah you know yeah because you keep it real right you say no no I don't want the I don't want the double pop out thing just get me a honey wagon
yeah but you can't make it back to the honey yeah I mean you're talking about one of those fucking fourpies yeah he means the fourpies one of those four slots Jason doesn't have that he doesn't even know what he's talking about because he's he's goes to the bathroom once in the morning before
shower and then he's never running the risk of going to the bathroom on set ever ever there's not a lot of animals on the planet that need to empty more than once a day will yeah you guys have a difference
in regularity yes we have a difference in regularity well listen I'm sorry to end on such a low point it wasn't that bad talking to us even just agreeing to do the show period yeah dude Jordan we're such
fans man I've been a fan of yours from everything you do I love what you do you're such a cool guy you haven't changed an iota so that's a great testament you're a good dude keep charging please thank you man you guys yeah on and on I love you love you this is
great I really hope I can come see you guys again yeah please more I'll come up with that scat story yeah good good scat story best of luck with with nope I'm gonna be first in line and hurry up and make more please
and just to you know just to take the James Cameron approach for a second I you know I'm finishing this movie right now it will make your eyes melt out of the back of your eye sockets fall down in through your nasal
and down your esophageal this is you selling the film you scat it out and and then you fucking eat you eat your eyes shit this is that we've got our quote and then you can see your own fucking heart pulse racing
save it for the junket Jordan wasting all the good stuff you got the exclusive hot take um no no I just want to stress it's it's it's it's gonna be a fucking spectacle yeah I cannot wait it looks so can't wait for you guys to see it all right man
best of luck thank you for coming on and we'll talk to you on the next one thank you guys honestly thank you Jordan I am I really I could get I could give you guys each I know will I know you I could give you guys each fucking solid power on neat notes
and how much I love your how much I love your work and so I didn't want to right back at you you guys are just fantastic I hope to hang yeah man that would be great luck dude take care Jordan bye buddy cool wow that Jordan
peel that Jordan peel he has turned the movie industry on his goddamn head by he barged his way into films didn't he yeah it just kicked the door open and it stayed open and now
he's bringing us I mean the horror genre is like one of the few genres that's working in in theaters still thank god yeah yeah but he's also but he's also doing it in such a cinematic way and he's like social themes that are in it so
he's so fucking smart you can't write a show like he and peel and do that so consistently and so fit and have it be so good and so funny for all those years and not be a fucking brilliant guy and just show him again I hope he wasn't like offended when I said you know that we knew him from all this stuff
and then get out came out and I was like wow Jordan like didn't you know he's like no way I mean I was offended he wasn't I was yeah no I could see it in Will's face but not Jordan he's gotta he's gotta know that he's gotta I mean I'm sure I would hope that
that was part of his excitement too that like you know whenever you excel at something you're not known for it's gotta be a thrill and so also like yeah you can't be mad if you're like some person who came not him I don't mean to him specifically but you could see how people
were like well yeah I've always thought I was great yeah well we didn't know yeah great yeah exactly and now we're now we're finding out that yeah you're great yeah exactly but I don't mean that for him I do think that what he did before I I always thought you know writing really consistently
good funny sketch like that doing it in that way is so hard yeah fucking you guys know it's almost impossible sketch is so uneven and and and and rarely people always go like oh I remember SNL back in the day was used to be way better than it is now is
funnier all the time like no there was always if you had one good sketch an episode success yeah for sure and Key and Peele now they didn't do it live but they they would have just brilliant it's just brilliant anyway um when I have a question about the Dodger game yeah so
um how long wait a second wait a second we we you want to talk about tonight's plans in front of our audience right now go ahead Sean they'll be sure they'd love to hear it where what root are you taking and where are you working what lot are you in do they have egg salad there do you think or should I eat before
I leave by the way all questions I have yeah let's hear it how long is the game oh my god he wants to leave already no no you even left your house yes you're getting ready to go tonight I didn't say how long is each half um it's a roughly
three hours but you know you only need to dip in and dip out for about an hour that's probably all we're gonna do because I'm bringing you know Maple um and and probably with shorter attention span is Amanda in fact she may actually even flake I can't believe that you got Amanda to go no man will go well because you know it's a luxury
suite you know so she she can be up there and uh you know watching the TV and and having snacks and sitting on a couch it's a luxury suites I'm just imagining that Paul McCartney explaining to somebody who he loves who he calls sweet and he's like why all of a sudden are we
it's a luxury sorry because we're back it's a luxury suite did you find a gummy store there in the Hamptons well no it does it does it does seem like a very high thing to say are you gonna bring your own food Jace are you going to no man buy it
buy it buy it I love Sean's he always he always goes high with it and he repeats it we're having a conversation over here and you're trying to do a buy on your own and like if you have a hard out
what if I just slam my left I guess buy I guess it counts well a better better answered here you know you will be out by 10 o'clock tonight Bye Smart
Loss Smart Loss SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf Bennett Barbicow and Michael Grant Terry
SmartLess I'm very excited that you're here oh my gosh my friend not more than I am not more than I am I cannot wait impossible yeah okay so you've met Bennett and Rob I am
sorry I met these guys on Jason's behalf we apologize for us the weird part is that Rob nor Bennett play any musical instrument at all that's the shocking part these are just CG backgrounds I don't believe it
this is a jam band that produced a new part Rob that's a real strong t-shirt you're bringing today show them the bottom show them the other stuff the in the studio behind the pro tools rig is the best is he playing a
keytar on the back I love it it is like it really is a very bootleg Han Zimmer shirt we went to Disneyland for Rob Andrea's birthday recently they were both wearing this shirt
at Disneyland matching can I tell you something I also have a picture I have a shirt that has Han Zimmer's face and the name Han Zimmer on it no way a completely different shirt I'm not joking
the idea that there's actually two shirts in existence on the planet that have Han Zimmer's name and face on it and the two dudes that have them this is everything there's very little I can do to actually make it clear that I do have that Kismet
should we let Will Arnett in the room I'm going dark awesome here we go There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.